16, 17?
VICIOUS, UNHINGED.
HERE WITH MORE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOE CONCHA.
THERE WERE THREE SETTLEMENTS.
NBC, "THE WASHINGTON POST," CNN.
THE CNN CASE, YOU HAD A SIMILAR
SET UP.
IT WAS THROWN OUT ORIGINALLY ON
JUDGMENT BUT ON APPEAL, HE GOT A
LOT OF MONEY FROM FAKE NEWS CNN,
NONDISCLOSED.
I'M SURE IT WAS SIGNIFICANT.
THIS KID DID NOTHING WRONG EVEN
WHEN THE VIDEOTAPE CAME OUT
SHOWING HE DID NOT APPROACH
MR. PHILLIPS.
THEY STILL CLAIMED HE DID.
AND THEY STILL CALLED HIM RACIST
AND HE'S NOT A PUBLIC FIGURE.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE THE TIME ZVI
SULLIVAN STANDARD.
I THINK HE WINS AGAIN.
>> ABSOLUTELY IF IT GOES TO
APPEAL.
YOU CALLED ANA NAVARRO A FAR
LEFT ANALYST.
REMEMBER SHE HAS CALLED A
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST WHEN SHE
IS INTRODUCED ON THE VIEW.
STRATEGIST FOR WHOM EXACTLY?
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR HOW MANY
WINNING CAMPAIGNS SHE'S DONE?
YOU'RE RIGHT, GIVING WHAT WE SAW
WITH "THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
CNN SETTLING OUT OF COURT.
THOSE WERE $250 MILLION LAWSUITS
AGAINST THOSE ORGANIZATIONS.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT THIS
JUDGE.
APPOINTED BY JIMMY CARTER BY THE
WAY.
DECIDES TO THROW THESE DUDES OUT
PURITY THINK ABOUT THE WAY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR
ROLLING STONE OR THESE OTHER
OUTLETS REPORTED ON
NICHOLAS SANDMANN, PAINTING HIM
AS BASICALLY THE FACE OF TEENAGE
RACISM.
NO DIFFERENT THAN THE WAY CNN
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST" DID
AND IT'S HARD NOT TO SEE THIS
RULING AS ANYTHING OTHER THAN
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED BECAUSE
CNN OR "THE WASHINGTON POST,"
THEY HAVE PLENTY OF LEGAL
RESOURCES.
THEY KNEW THAT IT WAS IN THEIR
BEST INTEREST TO SETTLE BECAUSE
THEY WERE ON THE LOSING SIDE OF
THIS ARGUMENT.
BASED ON WHAT YOU MENTIONED
BEFORE, THE VIDEO EVIDENCE THAT
ANYBODY CAN SEE AT HOME IN THE
CORDOVA PUBLIC -- THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION.
THE JUDGE SAYS WHERE'S THE BEEF?
THERE'S PLENTY OF BEEF.
SANDMANN CONTINUES THIS PURSUIT
AND HE WILL WIN.
>> Sean: HE WILL WIN, JUST
LIKE THE FIRST TIME WITH CNN,
THROWN OUT, SUMMARY JUDGMENT.
I WOULD ANTICIPATE ON APPEAL, AS
LONG AS H